[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en dépit d'un coût de la fatalité michel
petrucciani vit un conte de fées qui
peut m'en sens dans la ville d'orange le
papa d'un petit garçon handicapé de
naissance nous offre un piano il avait
alors quatre ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
michel petrucciani s'est également
prêtée au jeu du portrait chinois
première question si vous étiez un
standard du jazz un standard du jazz
saint martory sting et pour quelle
raison parce que mike police tient enfin
ses fans au besoin une chose folle pas
j'ai pas vraiment sérieuse n'est pas
trop sérieux à l'intérieur un sérieux
mais pas sérieux si vous étiez
[Rires]
je sais pas alors là c'est compliqué
d'abord parce que j'ai plein je ne
connais pas bien et les arbres non plus
je serai peut-être un saule pleureur
[Rires]
[Musique]
on
il
où
[Musique]